what's up this is ron killings WWE
superstar r-truth
we're playing star it's cut start [ __ ]
cut start [ __ ] this add more mm oh man
let's start that uh that Carter man
Carter starts a little plant will bet
for now but did you know ahead bets
means you're coming back on those that
just for now you just got to sit down
but net and we're gonna cut down what
you say yeah I guess I'd start with the
beat I mean pretty much in the order
your sitters beat then round the flow
beaches what is the starting to Bob to
it it's just starting you to like I'm
gonna open up to it the ROM you're like
you're miss knowing the flow comes in
and you can settle down and ride with
you nose and so they all have their own
positions for the [ __ ] cake crust start
r-truth
and we bake no no no cut okay crunch
bench okay quick start Audrey almost
mannequins like okay clothes for the
baby man you got to crawl before you
walk
then you got to walk before you run
so on and so on no blast was like me
coming up in the business like grateful
for all the things cake was done
accomplished but he pretty much just
started to set off motion to going okay
quick was matured but he wasn't grown
yet it's different train maturing wrong
yeah our truth is blown man he he got
together he know who here's a couple who
he is it was my boom oh you can cut the
time change convinced us title and give
me 20 bucks
but that connects me all Jones and
anything I will be on wrestling beyond
actresses actors beyond athletes
baseball football the 24/7 tiger can go
anywhere that's like that's how you
connect is how you make the people I
guess you can cut for your rumble you
can bench SummerSlam and I guess you are
WrestleMania
SummerSlam is pretty much the it's a
French to run to Wrestlemania you know
they're gonna go to one our second
biggest pay-per-view with SummerSlam and
it's always man like it's always in a
good spot
it's always hot it's always like
sometimes just SummerSlam two summits
around man that's my car that's the
prince
a ron killings aka r-truth a start bench
cut done now got it from me first hand
don't forget set it off is available all
did you look at forms go get it
listen to it want a visualize and see
you to set it off Ron kill start [ __ ]
cut start [ __ ]
cut